[Music]
[Applause]
Jeff pass an ESPN senior Baseball
Insider he is joining us from the city
of Seattle home run derby tonight at 8
Eastern on the mothership and ESPN2 I'm
curious at what point do you become an
Insider and do you declare yourself an
Insider
or or are you designated an Insider
Dan I've been an outsider my entire life
so I have no idea at which point I
became an Insider and it was 100
definitively not a self-appointed title
okay so I'm I'm going to leave that to
the uh to the others and uh just ride
the wave as long as I can all right
um serious question here can the
commissioner put Ellie De La Cruz into
the All-Star Game
yes
oh
okay he actually has like there's like a
commissioner's discretion Choice yeah
where he could where he could have done
that and he did not and and he didn't
because I I you know I think generally
speaking the commissioner uh in in the
many many years that this has been
available and by that I mean I think
it's been like once that he's done this
with Miguel Cabrera last year
um you know it tends to be for a
a veteran player a player who is uh
sailing off into the sunset and uh
that's the opposite of Ellie De La Cruz
but it you know if there was some sort
of uh special dispensation for a player
who's awesome and just broke onto the
scene and warrants inclusion yes I would
love to see that now I will give MLB
credit for this they invited Ellie De La
Cruz to the Home Run Derby and he did
and he declined the invitation I don't
know Dan
don't you
Derby is is like almost more of an event
now than the game itself I mean if he's
at the Derby he's going to be at all the
festivities he's going to be on National
Television he's going to be doing the
thing that you like seeing him do which
is hit balls really far among many other
things but I I don't think that the
difference between a derby invitation
and also invitations all that different
anymore in fact the Derby invitations a
lot rarer than an All-Star invitation
considering everyone and their mom gets
an All-Star invitation now because of
all the injuries and guys who are
pulling out yeah I guess you're right I
mean you know the nation wouldn't be
aware of Julio Rodriguez maybe as much
because of you know Home Run Derby Pete
Alonso has made a name or a bigger name
for himself there the Home Run Derby I
get it plus you would be able to have
him exposed to the media in different
markets that maybe wouldn't be following
the Cincinnati Reds and and you know
baseball needs more these stories it
feels like this this story is the
shoheiotani stay with the angels if
you're the Angels do you trade him what
happens at the trade deadline uh how
much is he gonna uh you know bring in as
far as a contract there that that is
just a looming cloud I don't know if
it's a dark cloud but it's a looming
cloud over Major League Baseball
oh yeah I don't think it's a dark cloud
at all I think the fact that Major
League Baseball has a story line that is
going to extend well into the NFL season
and be news and be like genuine and
legitimate news is a great thing for
baseball
but you know once the NFL starts then
every other sport has a really difficult
time
um
getting market share to to put it very
bluntly like the NFL is such a leviathan
it is such a it like an unrelenting
beast on our attention that baseball
always runs the risk of Fading Into the
background and becoming a sport whose
postseason is consumed only by fans of
the teams that are in it and the idea
that you're going to have this thing
this event in the off season that is the
most talented player we've ever seen
becoming a free agent and getting the
largest contract in North American
Sports history oh so you don't think
anything happens at the trade deadline
you think this story is going to be in
the off season oh no no no no no no not
suggesting that right now I'm I'm just
looking months ahead I think the trade
that line is turning into a fascinating
case because I think everyone who's
thinking logically in France offices
right now believes that the Angels
should trade othani before the deadline
not just because they like want him for
their own wait things really changed in
the last two weeks with trout injured
and they've lost nine of ten and now all
of a sudden okay but let's add some
logic to this we're talking to the
Baseball Insider Jeff passen for the
mothership okay
if I'm the angels and I go to show
ayotani's agent and I say
are you going to test the market
or do you want to start negotiations now
just let us know one way or another
because we as a franchise have to do
what's best for us and while we want to
resign him if you guys are going to test
the market we run the risk of not
getting anything for him
that conversation have those
conversations taken place
I I think that conversations like that
have taken place at some point I don't
know how recently though
but I gotta know that Jeff
if I'm the angels I have to say to
ohtani and his representative help us
let us know
do you want to stay here we're going to
make accommodations but if you want to
test the market then you're testing our
patients here and we're going to run the
risk of not getting anything when the
Dodgers come in and decide that every
night is going to be Japanese Heritage
night there
I don't disagree with your premise here
but I I also I I also think you're
simplifying it a little more not then as
logical you are being extremely logical
right now I think you're simplifying it
more than is realistic okay and I say
that because because the way that Arty
Moreno the Angels owner looks at it is
that we have a once in a lifetime player
and I'm not going to be the fool who
traded him and we're not going to give
another team an opportunity to
essentially spend the last two months of
the Season not just winning with him but
recruiting him and and you could be the
fool who didn't get anything for him
you're right and that has been the
Angels path the entire time that they're
going to be the fools who get like the
70th overall pick instead of getting an
enormous trade Hall and re-energizing
your uh your farm system at the deadline
and building a new Los Angeles Angels
without arguably the greatest player
ever the the conundrum here is not what
is the right thing to do all of us know
what the right thing to do is then the
conundrum is can the owner who has been
uh you know shooting himself in the foot
for essentially the past two decades
can he do what the right thing to do is
as opposed to letting his emotions about
the whole situation overwhelm him into
not because I don't think the angels are
making playoffs
thank you for your service we need to do
what's right for this organization we
hope that you're part of it we
understand though after six years of not
winning why you wouldn't want to be and
your first call would be to which
organization
I wouldn't have to make any calls I
would I would spend the next two weeks
for 24 hours on the phone with everybody
begging me to take their trade and I
would I would leverage it so hard and I
you know I would love to do it with the
Dodgers but with Artie Moreno not want
to send him to the Dodgers because of
the proximity
of course
what do you want to send them to the
Giants no because they're going to be in
the Mexican no I'm okay with the Giants
I can't have him with the Dodgers like
the Giants I could see and again your
whole here's the thing you're you're
your logic here falls on its face if you
trade him you trade him because you're
looking to get the bets package back you
need to divorce yourself I agree I agree
this is an owner the the ego of the
owner of of having Otani just down the
road and maybe we didn't get the best
deal but I can't be reading about him in
the LA Times every day I can't see him
on the local news every day put him in
San Francisco or some other place
you know Connie and I I you know where I
would like oh Tommy in Atlanta oh God I
just want to see him on that team oh my
God
it should be because they are a really
really okay
Paulie thinks the Braves he said the
Braves could win 116 games in the
preseason he said the Braves will win
116 games
I think they've lost too many to get to
116 right like isn't that is it 116 like
a 46 Lost season they don't have 29
already yeah well
there's you can't say no chance it's low
chance
I did take them to win the Warriors
before the season
the single wins it's a little aggressive
all right uh well Jeff thank you enjoy
the festivities there home run derby
tonight on the mothership at uh eight
Eastern he's a senior Baseball Insider
not to be confused with just an Insider
he's Jeff passing Jeff thank you for
taking the time
thanks buddy have a good one enjoy the
derby tonight that's Jeff Bassin